Nathan's with us in Pennsylvania Nathan
your question for dr. D and Dave how can
we help hey question is I'm a psychology
major and a counseling individual
similar to like John my question is
during these difficult times it's pretty
hard to make a decision about spending
any money at all and I feel like on the
mental aspect of things I have that
constant fear of wanting to spend any
money I'm such a saving person and my
question is for both of you is how can I
kind of loosen up with my spending a
little bit if I have the money
and make better decisions so my question
to you do what's your financial position
well my financial position currently is
I am in feeding step 3 be saving up her
house on a 20% so I'm really kind of
focusing on collecting as much money as
I possibly can
but I also feel like it's gotten to the
point where I kind of fell asleep that
you know I'm losing friendships and you
know it's affecting my relationships
with other people so how is how are you
losing friendships based on what you
spend I don't sound like much of a chip
I know it's a tough situation I guess
just a lot of my friends you know enjoy
doing activities and twenty five years
old so a lot of them like to do
activities even some activities that are
free you know involves a little bit of
travel and doing different types of
things so I guess on that aspect I don't
want to be know that friend you always
constantly says no to things yeah I
think I think you've got to strike a
balance and is your fear of money
apocalyptic or you always do you have an
end goal that you think is gonna come
take all your money away from you or is
it just a is it a hoarding thing like
where does that come from what does a
fear come from in you you know I think
where the fear comes from is comes from
other family members and friends who I
see spend our money recklessly and you
know
following the path from that situation
where they're asking for money from
friends and family and they lose their
homes in their cars and so you've got to
have that fear you've got a model you
got a picture what that looks like right
when that goes bad and see our aunt our
mentor there you go right you've got a
not want to be a mentor and so I would I
would strongly challenge you to a stay
with your convictions right those are
the things that keep you hold and well
but at the same time don't miss out on
friendships and opportunities if you're
out of debt you're saving for a house
you're already you're 25 years old
you're gonna be a mental health
professional which means you're never
gonna make a ton of money but you're
gonna be able to bring joy and happiness
to people you know what you've don't
miss out on your friendships and your
relationships okay
spend some money if that means going to
the movies going out having some fun
with friends take care of it enjoy your
life but if you have to spend rash
amounts of money to maintain a
friendship that's not a real sort of
friends that's right those aren't real
friends and so but if you're just
spending a little bit of time in order
to create time with folks that's
different a little bit of money to
create time with folks that's different
so it sounds like you know where you're
out of balance
dial it over one notch not ten notches
and you'll be okay